- Pete, Joe.
Congratulations.
You've made it into the final.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forges where you
will have to forge
an iconic blade from history.
Are you ready to see
what that weapon is?
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Absolutely.
The pandat.
Oh!
WIL (VOICEOVER): The pandat
is a two-handed sword carried
into battle by the
Dayaks, a group
of tribes that lived
on the island of Borneo
for thousands of years.
Though most Dayak weapons
doubled as useful tools,
the pandat was only used in war.
Forged from iron, the pandat
features an angled blade
and can be swung
downwards with two hands.
An iron cross piece was
inserted through a hole
at the end of the handle,
protecting the user's hand.
The blade was
sometimes decorated
with hair or rattan plant.
Until the early 20th
century, Dayak raiders
plundered coastal settlements
for resources, money,
and even enemy heads,
proving just how
deadly this weapon could be.
Good luck bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
This is home, Jenks, Oklahoma.
It's going to be hot.
It's going to be humid.
But I'm not worried about
anything other than an accident
or the unforeseen.
I mean, I have never
seen this blade.
I've never even heard of it.
A little apprehensive
about building it.
Five days-- it seems
like a lot of time.
But to build a piece
like this, it's going
to be really, really hard.
Come on.
Stay with me.
Don't-- don't power out on me.
What's going on?
Oh, wow.
I haven't seen it rain this
hard in a long time, y'all.
I mean, this is kind of intense.
Oh, [bleep].
OK.
Yeah, boys.
Damn it!
Go, go, go.
Stay where you're at.
Do not move.
Midway through day one,
everything's going great
and boom, amazing storm hits.
I mean, this thing was unreal.
There was some damage done.
We had a lot of trees down.
Took out, of course, the
meter and the power lines.
Doesn't look like we're going
to get power back anytime soon.
So we're going to
get a generator.
We're going to get it pumped up.
We're gonna get power and
juice back in the shop.
And then we're
gonna move forward.
[generator starting]
Yay!
We have power.
This was a pretty good setback.
It's reality check.
You go, hey, you sure you
got what it takes to do this?
Today is day three, and
I've been told it's Saturday.
There's gonna be a cutting test.
There's gonna be
a strength test.
There's going to be
a KEAL test, too.
So I want to draw my spine back
so it's a little softer so it's
got a little bit of flex.
So I rigged up kind of
an ancient way to do it.
I've dug a trench to
keep the edge cool,
so it won't get soft.
I've really been fighting
the wind with it.
But as fast as you get it
warmed up, it cools down.
I also have to keep
water in the trench.
When you've got a very hot torch
blasting against the water,
it evaporates rather quickly.
I'm not sure I'm
going to get it done.
Day four, either
we top the hill
or we roll down another one.
Today's a make or break
day for this blade.
We're going to quench this
thing and hope for the best.
And hopefully your
best is good enough.
Doing this is about as
nerve wracking as it gets.
You just want everything
to go nice and smooth.
It did harden, but I got
crazy-ass warpage right there.
It's a bit of a
kick in the pants.
We're running out of time.
Grind, grind, grind.
That's what it's
going to come down to.
And hopefully we'll
get that warp out.
Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
To see how sharp
your weapons are,
I will attempt to cut
through these web of ropes
with three identical strikes.
If they're sharp, I
should meet no resistance.
Joey, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Well, Joe.
All the weight is at
the tip of the blade.
So when I come down, it
wants to draw me forward.
And the recovery is a little
bit harder on the way back.
You have a sharp
edge over here that I
almost met no resistance.
Overall sir, your
blade will cut.
Pete, you're up next.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
OK, Pete.
It is a sharp blade.
The balance is light.
You have a lighter blade, here.
It's not as heavy
to pull forward.
It's a good job.
The only issue I have is that I
kind of ran out of handle here.
I would have liked to see a
little pommel here, or probably
even a longer handle
so it's easier
to control and not feel like
I'm at the end of my rope,
so to say.
Overall, this weapon,
sir, will cut.
Thank you.
All right bladesmiths,
next up is a kill test.
Now the pandat was a
weapon used by head
hunting tribes in Borneo.
To see how lethal your weapon
is, I will take your pandat
and I will deliver one
blow to this carcass.
Let's see how much damage
your weapon can do.
Joe, you're up first.
You ready?
Bring it.
Let's do it.
OK, John.
The balance feels
so forward-heavy
that when you slice through this
carcass, it pulled me into it
and cut cleanly all
the way through.
This weapon, sir, will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Pete, you're up next.
You ready?
Yes I am.
OK, Pete.
The difference with your
blade is that it's light.
And because it's light, I
can use velocity to help
cut through this carcass.
This weapon, sir, will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
This is the strength test.
To test the strength and
durability of your blades,
we're going to hook
them into our machine
here, which is going to chop
into this bundle of sugar cane.
Now, if your blades
are tempered properly,
they should cut into the
cane without a problem.
If not, we might get
them to bend, warp--
well, we'll see what happens.
Joe, you're already
rigged up on the machine.
You ready to go?
- Let's go.
All right.
Let's do it.
All right, Joe.
3, 2, 1.
All right.
So, Joe.
Now when I pull this
out of the machine,
there's a bit of
a bend right here
in the ricasso, kind of a
gap right along the edge
of the blade in the guard.
It had that warp
when it got here.
when it got here?
It was actually offset.
It's got a little
bit of a twist--
maybe a five degree twist.
I couldn't get it out
whenever I built it.
Well, it may have gotten
bigger during that test.
Overall, the edge held up fine.
No damage whatsoever.
It's got a good shape.
Good job.
Thanks, sir.
All right, Pete.
You're all locked in.
Ready for this?
I am.
All right.
All right, Pete.
3, 2, 1.
You can actually see how
much this blade flexed when
it went into the cane and
came back to true, which
is always what I want to see.
Definitely sharp,
well put together.
Feels good.
Well done, Pete.
Thank you.
Gentlemen, this is one of
the tightest competitions
that we've had.
It's exactly what we want
from our bladesmiths.
It was a difficult decision.
But that final
decision has been made.
And the Forged in
Fire champion is--
Pete, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion.
Joe, please surrender
your weapon.
This experience has taught
me, like many things in life,
to try.
Dare to fail.
If you fail, so what?
Feeling kind of
disappointed right now.
But at least I tried.
Pete, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion
and will be receiving
that check for 10 grand.
Good job.
Thank you.
[applause]
Pete, what I really
liked about your blade,
amongst many things, is I
wanted to grab that thing
and cut something with it.
And when I felt it--
I mean, it gives you the
woo to strike, you know?
It really does want to cut.
How you feeling
right now, Pete?
Feel pretty good.
I'm feeling like I could just
roll on the floor and bust
out laughing.
It feels real good.
Feels real good to win.
I'm going home the
Forged in Fire champion.
And I know all 24
of my grandkids
are going to be
excited for Grandpa.